foreign
comes from Casey in Arizona this is
going to sound so silly how strict would
you get with this with this debt payoff
we are 20 000 in debt with cars we
recently got married I am now pregnant
and my husband refuses to buy me any
soup
he wants us living off rice and chicken
I'm puking all day can't keep food
totally this is real for soup yesterday
this is real he makes very good money so
so one can of soup wouldn't hurt but
he's also dead set on not eating or
buying anything other than Essentials
we're literally fighting over it thanks
a pregnant wife crazy is that real y'all
oh my gosh see these this is the problem
with our job safe that we've created
means we will have a job that we've
created him whom oh no Casey yes no we
did not create him we never told someone
if you mean when we say live on beans
and rice rice and beans if you think we
mean that literally I mean you really
need to go back to school it's a
metaphor for sacrifice sacrificial
living the deeper you sacrifice the
faster you get out the chances when we
were dead dog broke in bankruptcy court
and my wife is carrying Rachel during
that moment Rachel was born the year we
filed bankruptcy the chances of me
telling Sharon Ramsey she ain't gonna
have any soups about zero
okay I would have woke up dead
I wouldn't have woke up at all I'm
telling you duct tape to the bed and her
standing over me with a baseball bat it
wouldn't I mean this would not have
worked right we are not gonna do this so
come on man come on man I mean really
goodness gracious now coughing well I
just remember how sick I was you were
sick pregnant and like that's so
terrible Casey go get soup go spend ten
dollars and get you ten cans of soup
tell Mr Pharisee to lighten up a notch
goodness gracious okay no we're not
buying a new car we're buying a can of
soup
jeez no I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know I don't know
we're both Spenders
I've had people call and say well I'm in
my my husband made me getting a dumpster
and get something out of the dumpster
because you said I never said that ever
never one time that I tell a man to
spend his wife to the dumpster to get
stuff out never once but I actually had
that call one time oh my gosh these
people take stuff listen you I get it
that you got the point but you missed
the point okay there's a concept here
not a detail yeah and so it's um
I think it was why Jesus was frustrated
with the Pharisees right oh yeah you got
the concept but you got all caught up in
the details and you went really far over
way over the line down the hole the
rabbit or Casey in Arizona if I had your
address Casey I would ship you a pallet
of soup a pallet yep just show it to the
rest of your pregnancy Costco Costco
here we go direct direct to Casey's yard
uh let's let's do a let's do a GoFundMe
for cases no no she doesn't need that
she needs to um well she's got it she's
got what she needs now